Donald Trump has scored victories in to
further presidential primaries in
Michigan and Mississippi Michigan's
being seen as the state which will test
the support of blue-collar workers the
Democratic contest there between Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders mineral is
neck and neck and I'm joined from Long
Beach in California by Peter Mathews
professor of political science at
Cypress College Peter thank you for
joining us more good news for Trump good
evening but just how significant is
Michigan for Trump's campaign it's very
significant we expected Trump would win
but by its by double-digit margins he
also wanted Mississippi by a huge margin
and that's two states swept by him and
you know the thing is the real I think
the interesting outcome with the Sanders
and Clinton is something that may
surprise a few people because Sanders is
now it was winning smaller states last
last week and this time it's a big
industrial State Michigan which Sanders
winning by about five to six percent 52
246 what's up with most the precincts
counted not all them accountable it's
going to happen in Sanders column but
both the night's going to be a very
interesting night all around and I think
it's it's very significant that Donald
Trump won their those two major states
and it's puts him in a really leading
position especially since the next
couple of primaries including in Florida
our winner-take-all that means that
whoever wins by a plurality of the vote
even just as long as the largest number
of single number of votes beyond the
other two would come in behind him that
first-place finisher first-past-the-post
you call it in Britain I believe for his
past the post will win all of the
delegates from Florida all of them not
just a portion of proportion of them is
it been passed so it's very interesting
that this is with Trump's two victories
if he wins next well he's already in
great position and if he wins Florida
it's going to really put him you know in
a position where it'd be hard to catch
up with him and it's of creating a big
conundrum for the Republican Party
leadership as you know Mitt Romney went
on nationwide speech the other day
trying to put put Trump in perspective
and warn the Republican voters that
Trump can be a real disaster for the
party if he is dominated that's their
point of view but we'll see what the
voters say we saw what they said today
but I'm looking at that standard
splitting race is very interesting as
well let's look at Trump because it is
it's very interesting he had added a
fairly difficult week with the
establishment attacking him openly you
have these super PACs coming out with
these ads against him and yet yeah
people are still voting for him and yet
he's not someone who is exactly heavy on
policy he's very heavy on rhetoric heavy
on policy why am light on policy excuse
me what's appealing to these people well
the people that he has that are
following him are usually lower educated
or lower income people have lost their
jobs to export to an outsourcing of jobs
and they're the called they would call
the Reagan Democrats many of them who
voted for Reagan blue-collar workers and
now they're coming back to the
Republican Party as Trump Democrats
interestingly not because they're
resentful there's a lot of that feeling
out there that the middle class has been
shafted and the corporation have taken
all the jobs overseas so Trump is
tapping into that especially when he
comes out against free trade agreements
that is the TPP which puts him an
opposite position most of the Republican
Party you know there for free trade and
Trump is actually taking some of Sanders
platformer bringing it together along
with other positions that make him
someone who can personally appeal to the
lower income under educated voters who
don't have the high formal education
their high school graduates most of them
and they're very resentful they see that
Trump is a man they said this guy's a
billionaire but he speaks our language
he doesn't talk in real long sentences
with analytical movements in his words
it's in says like very short punchy
lines and he addresses their personal
feelings and comes up with a solution
that they can identify with personally
and that's a very dangerous in sunway
talent for someone like him who could
take only the Republican Party off in a
different direction but the country if
he wins I think Hillary Clinton if she
wins the nomination will have a very
tough time beating Trump I know Sanders
also will have to work very hard to be
trumpet in the polls a one-on-one polls
it shows that Sandra's beats Trump by
thirteen percent and hillary beats Trump
by about six percent but this is just
early polls for November they're not
that predictable so Trump is the wild
card and he is on a roll believe me
everyone has to keep an eye on that
depending on what you wanted happen
America okay well let's look at
Clinton and Sanders this evening and
Michigan in particular who do you think
is going to emerge victorious there I
think it's going to be Sanders by a
small margin right now is about 5% five
points ahead of Clinton 52 246 and a
half and in the end when all the
precincts coming I'm going to predict
Sanders will probably take it unless the
precincts from Detroit are coming at the
end I don't think they're not coming at
the end this i'ma go ahead and predict
that Sanders will probably take this by
a few percent which will be very very
good for Sanders and that he was looking
for a big win like this he was winning
the smaller states the rural states such
as the ones that he won this past
weekend you know Nebraska and Kansas
which was pretty good for him I Hillary
took Louisiana now there's a thing that
we have to look at here everyone and
that is the african-american vote has
been solidly in Hillary Clinton's column
and that's the main reason may be the
only reason she's winning so many states
because the black vote black Americans
are voting for her overwhelmingly by
eighty percent of twenty percent and
Bernie Sanders been trying to make
inroads with them but hasn't been very
successful so far he's working on it
let's see what happens and if we um well
it's interesting that you say he's been
working on getting the african-american
vote because he has been involved in the
civil rights movement for decades so
it's it's um it's why isn't he appealing
to that demographic matter of fact he
was involved as a student university of
chicago in desegregating the housing
owned by the university and he got in
fact arrested with other
african-american demonstrators and
protesters tried to integrate housing
and he's had a record he was actually
marching with dr. King on the march on
Washington in 1963 and you would think
that he should have played that up and
let the african-american community know
that he's been involved with their
struggle for a long time he didn't do
that first he basically uses and Bernie
Sanders a type of politician that does
not use the personal appeal he is an
issues oriented politician he comes out
and says here are the issues here the
macro level issues why we don't have any
jobs in America anymore as big as even
exported because of corporations not
paying attention to the American worker
and globalization he talks about issues
and hopes that those issues will appeal
to voters and they have in Vermont
because people in Vermont knew him
personally but the United States people
the American people did not know his
personal story I didn't really feel that
comfortable bringing it out yet now he's
bringing it out in the beginning he
didn't and that's one reason the African
American voters probably one reason they
haven't flocked to his side yet those
numbers are coming up a little bit
though they're coming up to over twenty
percent not finally about twenty-seven
percent in some states and major
african-american figures such as Spike
Lee and others professor Cornel West
they've endorsed him and even the pop
culture folks like killer Mike that
brings some of the young people in so
he's bringing in some African American
endorsements that could be significant
as we go along I don't think he'll be a
successful as Hillary Clinton in this by
this election by June to win the
majority the african-american vote
because you only have a short time if
you had more time he would be able to
get I think over half their vote
eventually if you had more time but the
primaries are effectively over at the
end of at the beginning of June when
California votes as the largest state
but the hope that burning it burning has
is the largest states are going to go
for him you can bring in more delegates
that way